BRUNO AZIZA: Hi, everyone.
This is Bruno Aziza.
And today I'm excited
to introduce you
to a catalog of
reference patterns.
These are code
guidance that are going
to help you take advantage
of multiple products.
So BigQuery, data
flow, Pub/Sub, Looker,
our AI platform in the context
of your business needs.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, let's say you're trying to
build a product recommendation
system, or you're trying
to predict your prospects,
propensity to buy.
Well, you have the
opportunity to use
these solutions, if you will,
to accelerate your deployment.
We've learned this
from some of the best
customers we worked with.
And today we're making those
references available to you.
Now, to tell you how
they work and how
you can take advantage
of this, I've
invited Robert Saxby
on my team, who
is joining us from Amsterdam
to talk to you about them.
So first, Robert, thank you
for taking the time so late
in your day.
Let's start at the top.
What are these patterns?
ROBERT SAXBY: These
reference patterns, they
cover the kind of
spectrum of use cases
that we've seen with
different customers.
So let's give some examples.
Anomaly detection.
Let's say that you have--
you're a telco and you're
monitoring the system logs
coming from your calls.
And you want to make sure that
all the traffic on your network
is doing proper things.
You might want to spot
a bad actor, someone
that's going to DDoS one of
your services, for example.
So seeing those
anomalies has real value.
And with the technologies that
we make available in the Cloud
today, we've seen our customers
put these things together.
And then rather than have every
customer go out there and start
from the beginning, we want to
give them a kind of leap start,
let's say, and get them
70% of the way there.
So as you mentioned, we
bring the code, sample data,
instructions on both why
the pattern is useful
and how to use the pattern,
how to run the sample,
and then how to customize
it, and really importantly,
how to activate it.
One of the things
I've seen that I think
is really important when
you're in the Analytics space
is you're getting all
these good insights.
Once you've got those
insights, the next part
is how to operationalize
it, how to take
the results of that work and
actually activate it and make
it work for you and then
put the automation in there
so you can start using the
other folks in your company
to work on the next thing.
BRUNO AZIZA: That is great.
So in fact, today
we have a video
from [INAUDIBLE]
that's going to talk
about product recommendation.
If I'm a customer out
there-- actually it's
a Halloween video, so
it's also fun to watch.
If I'm a customer
out there, what
can I expect from that
resource in particular?
ROBERT SAXBY: Yeah, so let's
take a step back and think
about what a recommendation is.
So during this prolonged
period of partial lockdowns
and things, I found
myself doing more DIY.
And then I go online,
and I buy the next tool
or the thing I need.
And often when you buy
a product or service,
there are some
recommendations there.
For example, if you
buy a drill, then they
might suggest you
some drill bits that
will help you drill through
wood or metal or something
like that.
But there's a whole bunch of
stuff they could suggest you.
They could suggest an
extra battery or something.
Now, obviously, some
folks compile these lists
manually using their
specialist knowledge
that they have about the area.
But now imagine that you
don't have a catalog of tens
of products or hundreds.
You have thousands
or tens of thousands.
And rather than trying to
compile a recommendation
list for all these products,
all these tens of thousands
of products, why not let your
customer website behavior,
for example,
actually drive that?
So we have a
recommendation system.
We're looking at
the feedback that we
get from customers, whether it's
either explicit or implicit.
Implicit is the one we're going
after here because what we're
trying to do is infer
what customers like
by how often they
go back to a page
or how long they look at an
article, these kinds of things.
And then when we
take that, we're
able to correlate what
the item that someone
was looking at with other
items that they look at next.
And this we put into a system.
And basically what
we draw out of that
is a list of
products or services
that our customers
are actively, based
on their current behavior,
interested in buying
when they look at this
product or service.
And then when we get a customer
and they look at a product,
we can then recommend them
one of these alternative
or complementary products.
So it's real value there.
It helps you to
upsell, cross-sell.
It helps you to build a
better customer experience.
And there are many
ways of actually
going about building this.
The way that we've
got here is really
taking a canonical approach
based on the systems
that we make available
in Google Cloud.
So BigQuery, if you're
a data warehouse.
We're using Google
Analytics data,
which is a way to instrument
your website in order
to see what folks are doing, how
long they spend on page, which
page they go to next,
all that kind of stuff,
like the click-through
rates, convergence,
the things that are important
to analyze from your website.
We have a service that brings
that data into BigQuery.
And then in BigQuery,
as well, we actually
have an ML capability.
So we're able to generate,
based on the Analytics data,
recommendations using a model--
matrix factorization,
in this case--
and generate that list of
recommendations per product.
And now, here's the great thing.
It's not just-- as I
said, it's not just
about creating that list
or getting those insights.
The next step is how
to activate that.
So when you look at
[INAUDIBLE] video as well,
you'll see the whole journey
here-- how to get the data,
how to do the preparation of the
data, how to train the model,
and then how to
do the predictions
and then how to activate that.
So you might be asking
yourself like, OK,
that sounds like a lot of work.
How long is it going to take?
Well, as I said, the sample
data of the code is there.
I would set someone
a challenge and say,
spend a couple of hours
running through the sample.
And then based on our
sample data on this,
you'll be generating
those recommendations.
And then follow the steps
on how to customize and add
in your own data.
And then before
you know it, you'll
be looking at your own data,
your own Analytic data,
and start generating
recommendations
for your own company.
BRUNO AZIZA: That was great.
So all these come with
a simplified two-pager
that is going to allow
you to really structure
your deployment,
simplify your approach,
and then scale this
inside your organization.
We're putting the link down
here of all the other ones
that are available to you.
We hope that you're
going to enjoy them.
We hope that they're going
to help you accelerate
value inside your organization.
And of course, if
there's anything
that you would like
us to build for us,
or you'd like to find out more
about how other customers are
building, let us know simply
by putting a comment down here.
Robert, thank you so much for
staying up late to talk to us
about this.
I'm sure lots of people are
going to reach out to you.
We'll talk to you soon.
ROBERT SAXBY: You're welcome.
Thanks a lot, Bruno.
Bye-bye.